hola Senora senorita and welcome to fast
of jazz's
it is a true story of a man with a great
beard we shall now pray for it to start
thank you
[ __ ] do you think this sensitivity
sensitivity is alone let me see here I'm
just gonna there alright
while this game is my favorite game so
far I'm so excited for this game I've
been waiting since a decade for this to
come out just spin [ __ ] praying
everyday Jesus since Lazarus has
returned to the living it's converting
everyone he is converting a bunch of
zombie well that's his [ __ ] great the
first thing I read and it's not even
proper well that's the best story I ever
heard let's punch this cheap shall we
can't punch anyone apparently it's also
very what is this [ __ ] ah ah what do you
want from it all I want oh I can I can
[ __ ] you cheap you cheap [ __ ] get it
[ __ ] you zombie to [ __ ] Egyptians son
of AB that's racist against Egyptians
how is this fist
this is hi fireman hi-5 zombie well how
am I suppose he was supposed to know
that he died from it level glorified I
[ __ ] beat that [ __ ] I'll go with it
the game does not want me to make a
decision huh you have like a training
stage perhaps later perhaps later fine
you know what fine I'll do it you can do
it come on I believe in you
yes you can load it's an iPad game loud
now
ah it does not want to load it what do
you want from me Jesus did not kill
zombies this is not even correct
let's practice to the fish throwing when
you see a leaper near what do i do what
do i do wanna see a leaper near well I'm
just gonna collect these fascists
fascists no fishes whatever I don't know
what you want from me Jesus Christ
literally okay here we go alright so I
am purchase and I will indeed
throw a Fache in the past god damn you
guys are ugly Jesus did not die for this
Uncle Ben did not die for this what do
you guys think about this game so far
I'd say it's pretty goddamn beautiful
hold the attack button for stronger
attack got it chris is charging that
time what the [ __ ] was that what is that
well what has been son cannot be on son
poor chickens oh my god what am i doing
to them [ __ ] sell the rip-off I
thought this game would be [ __ ] but it's
shiny shiny asses it has Chinese law
Sharia fetches your 55:8 Oh el gato and
chicken a colossus I'm a charge in my
faces say say say say say say Madre
assume Patrick that means I like you
with Jesus scares me every time another
training we shall conquer it burrows
Judas is so Sugoi he's Judas is so chibi
yes I glorified that [ __ ] right in the
ass
sorry god dammit Judas why did you have
to be social Sequoia stab you I stab you
he's so cute I'll call you Jerri now
Jerri we need you game
hi Jerri you're back
I tore this [ __ ] place
what the hell I got in my robe go Jerry
go this is amazing what the [ __ ] is that
fish do in there
fishy yeah I mean awesome go fishy it
gave me so can't wait what was that
how did I do that Judas you're amazing
look at that ass oh he's wearing pink
panties ridiculous I have the same
underwear as Judas who would've died
what that [ __ ] is that nope nope not
going in that [ __ ] let's wrap punch that
[ __ ] for having way too long arms o
date says divine punishment don't look
bridge that was horrible Jesus clearly
hey what's up Ed's
that's not what I meant damn it Judas
you're on fire literally glorified so
it's amazing the more I play the more I
ship them all right now towards the bus
battle Oh God nice to see you thanks for
resurrecting me kamehameha haha oh [ __ ]
oh damn it Lazarus imma have a jet I
don't think Burgers existed back then
that's the most unrealistic part about
this game not the fact that I have pink
underwear
go go go go shut them out of pink
underway crisis yes
slap my [ __ ] up is that a fish phone
give me stop smacking my ass I may have
a glorious ass but only I can slap it
throw fishes at him that's right [ __ ]
aah aah
quistis Judas finish him Oh juices has a
special ability go Jesus
oh he's constable no this spontaneous
combustion didn't work
it goes into empty life [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this isn't there this is very bad
this is very bad go go go go go go go go
go go go go go okay so Sugoi weird in a
browser rescue me over Tina you defeated
me they stamp it out mr. Richter game
perfection I press I think that'll be a
good part to cut it there but you
enjoyed watching this video I sure as
hell enjoyed playing at that like button
Bruce really appreciate it
it's a Scott I come abroad today and I
will see you in the next one as always
stay awesome